The longest novel in the world as recognized
by the Guinness Book of World Records is A
la recherché du temps perdu by Marcel Proust.
Within its pages are an estimated 9,609,000
characters, including spaces.
When classical music is played in restaurants,
people spend more money on wine.
At his execution, Louis XVI was too fat to
fit into the guillotine.
In 2012, the fifth-oldest tree in the world
was burned down by a crystal-meth addict.
The smell of freshly cut grass is a plant
distress call.
When you cut the grass it is actually crying
out for help.
The second episode of the The Muppets was
called 'Sex and Violence'.
Diamonds can actually boil!
They have an absolute boiling point of 4300
degrees Kelvin assuming particular atmospheric
conditions are met.
There are more than 915,000,000 ways to combine
six standard Lego bricks.
The Boy Scouts' motto 'Be prepared' was originally
followed by 'to die for your country'.
By 2019, there will be more Lego figures on
Earth than people.
Scientists estimate that between 1986 and
2007, humankind has gathered 295 exabytes
of data in digital storage around the world.
That's 295 million terabytes!
But that's still less than 1% of the total
information stored in human DNA.
The Royal Navy uses blasts of Britney Spears's
'Oops!
. . . I Did It Again' to scare off Somali
pirates.
For Irish based surnames, the prefix “Mac”
means “son of”, and the prefix “O'”
means “grandson of” or “descendant of”.
Rain following a dry spell is often accompanied
by a pleasant smell that permeates the air.
That smell is known as “petrichor”, and
it's believed to be caused by organic compounds.
The appropriate response to 'How are you?'
in Luxembourgish is 'Tip-Top'.
Our modern word “ostracize”, which means
to “exclude (someone) from a society or
group” according to the Oxford Dictionary,
comes from the Ancient Greek practice of ostracism,
where Athenians could force another of their
number into an “honorable exile” after
a majority vote.
This was often used by political rivals to
literally remove their opponents from the
scene.